während hier heute die luft sirenen
geheult haben und ich gleichzeitig den
worten für video von
brasiliens geht dem ukrainischen
präsidenten gelauscht habe konnte ich es
kaum glauben was danach passierte die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin
göring-eckardt machte weiter nach seiner
rede nach den emotionalen worten nach
dem hilferuf an deutschland mit
geburtstagsglückwünsche das war die
direkte reaktion auf die rede des
ukrainischen präsidenten der deutschland
kritisiert hat der auf die fehler
hingewiesen hat und der um hilfe ja man
muss sagen gefleht hat ich kann nicht
verstehen dass eine bundestags-
vizepräsidentin so wenig
fingerspitzengefühl hat dass sie
tatsächlich mit geburtstags wünschen
weiter macht und ich kann auch nicht
verstehen wie olaf scholz der deutsche
bundeskanzler ist nicht geschafft hat
auf diese rede zu reagieren auch wenn es
nicht auf der so genannten tagesordnung
deutscher wird auch heute haben nicht
mehr also der tagesordnung stand das ist
danach anders weitergehen sollte hätte
olaf scholz reagieren müssen ich finde
katrin göring eckardt olaf scholz
annalena baerbock sie alle sollten sich
beim ukrainischen präsidenten dafür
entschuldigen was das für eine
veranstaltung war der mann der hier um
sein leben kämpft bank der um das leben
so vieler menschen hier schon trauern
muss der sich zeit genommen hat vor dem
deutschen bundestag zu reden wurde dann
so schroff abgebürstet damit dass man
einfach weitergemacht hat mit der
tagesordnung mit geburtstags wünschen
und das hat mich heute wirklich massiv
geärgert
das war in der tat extrem peinlich ich
saß ja im parlament habe die rede vom
ukrainischen präsidenten gehört das war
eine sehr bewegende rede die wirklich
sehr viele von uns auch emotional
berührt hat und was danach ablief das
war wirklich peinlich und beschämend und
ich will mal hier ein bisschen aus dem
nähkästchen plaudern das kam ja nicht
überraschend dass die rede heute
stattfand und wie die tagesordnung
aussah sondern man hätte all das schon
wissen können was sie ja ronzheimer
und sich darauf vorbereiten müssen und
man hätte danach eine aussprache zur
aktuellen situation in der ukraine im
deutschen bundestag durchführen müssen
es hätte eine erklärung vom
bundeskanzler olaf scholz geben müssen
danach eine debatte bei der sich alle
fraktionen beteiligen statt dessen gibt
es direkt danach geburtstagsglückwünsche
und man fährt in der tagesordnung fort
als ob nichts geschehen wäre ich kann
noch mal vielleicht so ein bisschen
vertraulich hier sagen wir haben als cdu
in den tagen vorher explizit darauf
hingewiesen und gesagt liebe
ampelkoalition ihr müsst die
tagesordnung ändern wir können dann
nicht mit geburtstagsglückwünsche
weitermachen und mit einer ganz normalen
tagesordnung als ob nichts geschehen
wäre und dieser wunsch wurde leider
abgelehnt und das hat uns heute in der
ganzen welt blamiert was da
stattgefunden hat herr müller hat es uns
einmal zu ihnen geschadet hat es uns in
der ganzen welt blamiert oder blamieren
wir deutschen uns eh schon seit längerem
mit blick auf die ukraine
naja erstmal schön guten abend alle
beteiligten ihres los angeles
kleinigkeiten da waren die deutschen
noch nie darüber kann man verlegen es
ist glaube ich sagt alles aus das hat
paul ja vorhin jetzt schon gerade gesagt
dafür haben ganz einfach die worte aber
da könnte ich jetzt mit einer großen
lettern anfang von der bundeswehr
angefangen bis hierhin ich sehe und habe
auch noch keinen gesehen der das gelbe
ich habe es leider in deutschland
vergessen dass da das gerät bezeichnen
auch mal getragen hat dass die
zugehörigkeit und in
zusammenhalt und dass man hinter den
soldaten steht bei irgendeinem politiker
gesehen noch nie also
damals bei guten welt als sie mit dem
mal irgendwo eine sendung war vielleicht
das letzte mal worauf ich aber darauf
hinweisen möchte ist heute ein ganz
spektakuläres
instagram video herausgekommen von
meinem freund governor schwarzenegger
der auch schon viele jahre mit vitali
und wladimir klitschko
befreundet ist also wir kennen uns alle
schon über 20 jahre ich habe mit beiden
auch einmal trainiert und wenn sie hier
in los angeles waren wir haben auch
teilweise
telefoniert braucht ihr das ging jetzt
geht es im moment nicht nur 23 minuten
also andererseits werden sie geortet auf
jeden fall an die beiden sicher in der
ganzen karriere immer für die angeht
also eingestellt oder
geholfen die im grunde herrn
verbrauchten und
jetzt müssen wir sie halt unterstützen
und da gibt es viele möglichkeiten
tagtäglich es kommt dann schon mal
schickt man hört man überall die
gleichen auf die nachrichten die sind ja
auch wichtig dass wir darüber reden das
ist ganz toll ich bedanke mich dafür
dass man das hier mal sagen kann aber
hier in amerika oft verzweifeln wir
schon zum größten teil über unseren
präsidenten beiden her wir haben die
möglichkeiten wirklich lügen und alle
sachen nach deutschland zu schicken von
alaska gouverneurin von alaska hat
gesagt ich kann die ganze welt versorgen
so viel öl habe ich der präsident muss
nur ja sagen das heißt also wir würden
aufhören und bräuchten nicht jeden tag
eine milliarde dazu den zu putin
schicken um seinen bruder krieg diesen
brutalen unnötigen und schlimmen krieg
zu beenden das ist ganz ganz wichtig es
ist ja so als wenn wir benzin ins feuer
gießen jedesmal und auf anderen seite
soll gelöscht werden also wie gesagt da
können wir noch dass leute wenn ich das
ergänzen darf ich habe dass ich erwarte
gar keine entschuldigung gegenüber als
lenski oder keinen kann kann keinen
selbstkritischen blick auf die welt ich
finde dass diese koalition sich vor uns
vor den deutschen entschuldigen muss das
war eine extrem würdelose geschichte und
mit den geburtstags wünschen das geht ja
noch an aber keinen gehört hat dann
nachbesetzungen in einigen stiftungen
und gremien bekannt gegeben unter
anderem im stiftungsrat der stiftung
haus der kleinen forscher wenn man diese
rede von zielinski gesehen hat und dass
danach kam dann war das sozusagen auch
die beschreibung des hauses der kleinen
der kleinen geister in denen man da saß
der lenski hat mit dem bild gearbeitet
dass die deutschen die mauer einreißen
sollten die sie trennt von der ukraine
und von dem was östlich von der ukraine
ist und damit da in diesem bild ist er
bestätigt worden durch das was im
bundestag passiert ist weil man ich
glaube dass die deutsche politik immer
noch nicht begriffen hat dass die zeit
von putin vorbei ist dass man darüber
reden muss was man tut wenn putin weg
ist wie man der ukraine nach europa
hilft wie man europa neu ordnet die
sitzen da fühlen sich auf sicherem
terrain glauben dass die energieimporte
öl und gas sind gesichert wird uns
nichts passieren der winter wird nicht
kalt und damit lassen wir die sache mal
laufen die deutschen waren mit den
beschlüssen zur aufrüstung und zur
waffenlieferung an die ukraine aus ihrer
sehr schlechten position raus und jetzt
sind sie wieder in einer sehr schlechten
drin für mich für mich als deutscher
teilnehmer der zeitgeschichte ich finde
es erbärmlich ich finde es völlig
unmöglich dass man auf eine solche rede
nicht sofort eine debatte aufsetzt und
über die situation in der ukraine redet
und wäre die drei parteien der ampel
übersah und lass mich das noch sagen
paul die drei parteien der der ampel
haben eine ganz andere partei tradition
die spd ist die partei des friedens
nobelpreisträgers willy brandt die
grünen waren immer eine friedenspartei
die fdp war in der sozialliberalen
koalition auch eine friedenspartei dass
die das so an sich vorbeigleiten lassen
und sich durch die begründung ihrer
verweigerung der diskussion in eine
immer noch unmögliche situation hinein
reden und ihnen das gar nicht auffällt
das erlebt man wirklich selten zu eher
selten paul
weiß was mich interessiert du hast sie
angesprochen das ist auch sozusagen für
die natürlich für die deutsche
bevölkerung einfach peinlich war was
dort passiert ist und das ist ja auch
das was natürlich wo uns oder oder euch
in dem moment am meisten beschäftigt nur
ich frage mich was er bloß gesagt hat
ist war ja vorher in der diskussion oli
keiner kennen den parlamentarischen
betrieb so gut wie du was glaubst du
denn warum das dann nicht verhindert
wurde lag es daran dass man nicht auf
die opposition eingehen wollte und sagen
wollte mensch okay da hat friedrich merz
einen punkt machen wir anders
woran liegt es dass ist ja irgendwie
rückt ja also wir haben die debatte auch
bei drei tage lang ja ich glaube die
koalition hatte erst davor was sie
lenski sagt das wussten sie ja nicht
also wenn zielinsky die deutsche
position zu sanktionen beispielsweise
frontal angegriffen hätte und
forderungen erhoben hätte hätte das
natürlich in der nachfolgenden
diskussion eine rolle gespielt also das
wäre natürlich aufgenommen worden von
wem auch immer
und das wollten sie vermeiden deshalb
haben sie sich in diese völlig
unmögliche situation rein begeben und es
gab eine nach meiner sicht einmalige
situation weil der
oppositionsführer der cdu csu friedrich
merz unterstützt worden ist von einem
redner der linkspartei nämlich von jan
korte da kommt glaube ich als hamburg
der hat ihm heftig zugestimmt also der
hat sozusagen von links auch noch die
koalition angegriffen weil er der
meinung war darüber muss man einfach
reden das war eine heim hat olaf scholz
ja immer gesagt wir führend bestellt
bekommt sie auch ja der inkom logan
genau mit dem slogan ist er in der luft
zu bleiben hat sie gar nicht hätten sie
haben einen solchen moment bekommt
deutschland diese führung nicht sondern
deutschland ist führungslos und olaf
scholz hätte natürlich heute antworten
müssen vor allem hat paul ronzheimer
eben ja auch ein paar fragen aufgeworfen
die man im deutschen bundestag hätte
diskutieren müssen wir müssen ja auch
nach paar wochen feststellen was ist gut
gelaufen was kann man vielleicht noch
stärker machen ob bei den sanktionen
aber was ist auch schief gelaufen und
dass man nur eine große debatte im
deutschen bundestag darüber hatte
nämlich an dem sonntag bei der
sondersitzung das jetzt ja auch schon
eine gewisse zeit her das ist wirklich
beschämend und ich hoffe dass wir
schnell diese grundsatzdebatte zur
ukraine im deutschen bundestag bekomme
ich glaube paul dass diese koalition ein
schlechtes gewissen hat wegen ihrer
verspäteten reaktionen auf den krieg
wegen ihrer zu schwachen reaktionen
wegen ihrer verweigerung von energie
importen aus russland
es hat ja noch ein kleineres
sanktionspaket inzwischen gegeben wo
deutschland dafür gesorgt hat dass
sanktionen gegen investitionen in der
russischen energiewerten sensoren
sprechen ich gedacht